[Music]
on this monday night the unrelenting
violence in the middle east
[Applause]
airstrikes from israel hamas rocket
attacks
the women and children killed and the
u.s president's new support for a
ceasefire
manitoba now canada's worst coveted hot
spot
we need to bring down these numbers the
strain on hospitals and what will it
take to bring the number down
your work and your health my back hurts
my
eyes hurt my brain hurts how long hours
can shorten your life and hoop dreams
come true
the ultimate honor for this toronto
raptors super fan
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is no let up in the violence in
the middle east israel's prime minister
says he does not intend to stop
attacking gaza despite mounting global
pressure and
outrage at the civilian casualties and
hamas
keeps firing back israeli airstrikes
have killed at least 200 people in gaza
the palestinian health ministry says 59
children
and 35 women are among the dead israel
says it struck 110
targets last night it says it only
targets hamas and islamic jihad which
have fired thousands of rockets at
israel
but as hospitals in gaza are overwhelmed
with the wounded
doctors too are being killed dr ayman
abu aloof was head of internal medicine
at gaza's biggest hospital
he was killed when an israeli missile
hit his neighborhood early sunday
he trained new doctors at that hospital
dr mauin ahmad al-alul was killed
too he was one of the few neurologists
in gaza
israeli civilians have endured the
constant threat of rockets fired
indiscriminately from gaza
israel's iron dome defense system
intercepts most of them
but dozens of israelis have been injured
and at least 10
have died an international push for a
unified call
for an immediate end to the hostilities
has been thwarted by
israel's top ally the united states
we'll have more on that in a moment but
we begin
with the air strikes israel says it has
many more targets to hit in gaza
and is ignoring increasingly loud calls
it is using disproportionate force
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
a rare uplifting moment a six-year-old
girl rescued in the rubble in gaza city
but there is little joy her mother and
four siblings were killed her father
lies by her side in hospital after a
night of what's being called the
heaviest bombardment yet from israeli
airstrikes there is by daylight
evidence of widespread destruction and
death three apartment buildings were
destroyed this weekend
they kept bombing says this gaza
resident they should hit those who hit
them
not the poor people in their homes
israel says its air campaign is designed
to target hamas
one commander was killed in this car and
says several kilometers of hamas tunnels
were destroyed
we've struck hundreds of other
underground targets inside gaza
and that's the one incident where we saw
houses collapsing as a result so we're
looking into it
and i want to be clear it is not our aim
we have no business killing civilians
hamas rockets also continue to be
launched and while most are intercepted
many are getting through some israeli
residents voiced support for the
military
we have to continue until there is a
long-term cease-fire says this man
israel's prime minister benjamin
netanyahu has declared again the israeli
campaign will continue
and hamas is not asking for a ceasefire
either we think about netanyahu and
hamas
they both benefit from this they
represent more extreme and violent
factions of each society
they're not doing good they're taking
advantage of people's worst emotions
for their own political gain israel's
aim to impose a heavy cost on hamas says
this expert it wants to re-establish
deterrence
it wants hamas to think twice about
firing
rockets across the goal for hamas once
to show it can stay in the game
that it can surprise the israelis that
it's remarkably
resilient and and that's why it will
continue to fire rockets
the arab world is large and frustrated
in many cities anger is boiling
negotiations have done nothing says this
man he hopes the fighting will lead to
the so-called liberation of palestine
but military superiority is with the
israelis
ground bombardment so far is coming from
the border a reminder that the conflict
could turn even more deadly
if israeli ground forces start moving
into gaza
eric sorensen global news toronto
canada has joined other countries
calling for a restraint on all sides and
an immediate end to the violence
in a statement global affairs says the
toll particularly on civilians including
women and children
has already been too great it says
canada supports israel's right to live
in peace
with its neighbors with insecure
boundaries and fully supports israel's
right to assure its own security
this right also comes with immense
responsibility and obligation
to act in accordance with international
law
the u.s is israel's greatest ally and
provides more than three billion dollars
in aid every year
its position has always been israel has
the right to defend itself but
how far does that go a growing number of
americans including members of president
joe biden's own party
want him to do more to pressure israel
to end the violence
late today biden spoke to israel's prime
minister and afterward put out a
statement
supporting a ceasefire but not calling
for an immediate end to the violence
jackson proskow reports his progressive
administration has adopted a decidedly
familiar stance on middle east conflict
palestinians and israelis equally
deserve to live in safety and security
and enjoy equal measure of freedom
prosperity and democracy
as hamas rockets are fired into israel
and as israeli bombs rain down on gaza
the biden administration has remained
staunchly in the corner of america's
longtime ally
there is no equivalence between a
terrorist group indiscriminately firing
rockets at civilians
and a country defending its people from
those attacks
but at home biden faces growing pushback
from those who believe the u.s needs to
do more to protect palestinian civilians
including a growing number of fellow
democrats and progressives
in a new york times op-ed senator bernie
sanders wrote
we can no longer be apologists for the
right-wing netanyahu
government adding israel has the
absolute right to live in peace and
security
but so do the palestinians our approach
is
through quiet intensive diplomacy
and that's where we feel we can be most
effective biden has spoken privately
with both palestinian and israeli
leadership
speaking with israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu late monday
biden said he supports both israeli
self-defense
and for the first time a the united
states is just trying to minimize
its role and i would be very surprised
if there's anybody
at the top of the biden team or
administration who's saying here's a
chance to push the parties towards peace
generations of american presidents have
tried and failed to broker a lasting
peace
the biden administration says it
believes a two-state solution is the
best way
it's unclear if it's willing to help
foster one let alone wade into the
current situation
yet the u.s retains considerable
influence here the biden administration
authorized 735 million dollars in arms
sales to israel just days before this
latest violence erupted
that's on top of billions of dollars in
continued u.s military support
donna jackson proskow in washington
thanks
now to this country the federal
government is expecting a major boost to
the vaccine supply
this week roughly 4.5 million doses of
pfizer biotech and moderna vaccines are
expected to be delivered
more than 17.2 million canadians have
now had at least
one dose that's more than 45 percent of
the population
in manitoba more than 50 percent of
adults have now had at least one dose
that is good news but vaccinations
haven't happened fast enough to protect
a rising number of people
who are getting sick manitoba now has
the highest active infection rate per
capita in all of canada surpassing
alberta
over the last week 232 of every 100
000 people in manitoba tested positive
and that has put a serious strain
on hospitals this has been
15 months that we've been dealing with
covet 19
but we certainly need to stay focused
brittany greenslade reports on what has
led to this surge in cases in manitoba
and what's being done to get it under
control
hospital beds are full intensive care
units are bursting with patients
and the province is routinely hitting
some of its highest case counts of the
pandemic
daily we need to bring down these
numbers there's far too much strain on
our health care system there's far too
many manitobans
in icu and hospital with covert 19 right
now
there are now 120 patients in the icu
more than 60 percent are covet related
and with an average of six new patients
being admitted to the unit every day
the province is close to surpassing its
second wave peak
in wave two our peak capacity was 129
and it did not feel good it felt
everybody was stretched
everybody was stressed everybody was
tired
and not feeling good about the situation
for sure
and that next peak may not be far off
manitoba has the highest covet 19
infection rate in the country now
surpassing alberta's
and hitting more than twice the national
average the province firmly rooted in
its third wave
health officials say is being driven by
variants and people failing to comply
with health orders
what we're seeing in many jurisdictions
is that this third wave this
variant is much more infectious
and we're going to see that that spike
which we're seeing now so we do need
manitobans to
to adhere to these restrictions for a
while longer
while we see the benefits of those
vaccines manitoba increased restrictions
further a week ago
gyms restaurants and places of worship
are closed
no visitors not
if we available any indication of a peak
occurring
but like we we often say is we don't
think take things off the table
if we're going to protect manitobans if
necessary
brittany greenslade global news winnipeg
there are signs alberta's third wave is
starting to ease
after nearly two weeks of tighter
restrictions case numbers are starting
to drop
but hospitals are still dealing with a
surge in illness
there are now more patients in intensive
care than ever before in alberta
and as heather urex west reports it's
expected to get worse
before it gets better our health care
system
is under significant stress more than at
any point during the pandemic
it is something that alberta knew was
coming
after weeks of very high daily case
numbers
covet 19 patients are now arriving in
hospital
in need of care there are currently 241
patients
186 with covid now in icu
that is easily the most icu patients
that we've ever seen in our health care
system and definitely higher than what
we've seen in waves one and two
the system has space for up to 425 icu
beds
the problem is finding staff to support
them for us to be able to redeploy staff
to icu so we've had to reduce
our scheduled surgical activity in some
communities by up to 30 percent
this has a significant impact on those
albertans who are waiting for non-urgent
scheduled surgery late last week alberta
health began reporting the total number
of icu patients on its website
as the number of covet patients seen in
red increased
the percentage of non-coveted patients
fell that's because the province has
already cancelled some non-urgent
surgeries
but as of may 14 intensive care units
were more than 93 percent
full fortunately the number of new daily
infections in alberta
now appears to be coming down the good
news is
we're very close to the peak of icu
we just don't know when it's going to be
and we don't know what the
the number will be but clearly it will
most likely be higher than we are now
and and this is clearly at a peak that
we've never been at before
it's why the province is putting new
contingency measures
in place in previous waves a field
hospital was built in calgary
and at edmonton's butter dome the sites
have never been used and remain
ready still ahs now has plans
to build two more heather urex west
global news
calgary some breaking news now the
public health agency of canada has named
a replacement for major general danny
fortan
brigadier general christa brody will
take over as head of logistics for the
federal vaccine rollout
as abigail beeman reports forte was
forced to step aside
because of a military investigation
linked to an allegation
of sexual misconduct based on the fact
that they require the right
three days after major general danny
forte was forced to step aside from one
of the government's biggest
files fortan's lawyer tells global news
his client still doesn't have details of
the allegation
via official channels saying it is a
news reporter who informed major general
forte of the allegation against him
sunday may 16. this took him completely
by surprise
he vigorously and categorically denies
this allegation
ctv reported forte is being investigated
for exposing himself before a woman
in 1989 when he was a student at the
royal military college in saint jean
quebec
the investigation is being led by the
canadian forces national investigative
service
military lawyer michelle drapeau
believes the investigation could be
complete
but says it could be several months
before military prosecution makes a
decision about next steps
including any charges we had this bad
news
on trusted upon us at the end of the
week
without any explanation a more explicit
message
could have been provided by if not by
the defense ministry but the prime
minister
as to what the nature of the allegations
were
the prime minister took part in an
announcement monday but took off before
the media
q a leaving his ministers to field
questions about forte
i've been sitting on the cabinet covid
committee since the very beginning and i
can assure canadians that it won't have
any impact in terms of the operational
capacity
of the caf to deliver public health is
not
a monday to friday nine to five
job right now crisis communications
specialist jeff
chatterton says there's no excuse for
not having a more immediate announcement
about next steps
i think canadians are just tired i think
canadians are just
done they don't care who's in charge
they don't care what his name is they
want someone to be
in charge they want someone to stick
needles in arms and get us out of this
mess
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the occupational hazards of working too
much coming up how long hours could cost
you your health
plus the day people in the uk have been
waiting for
the pandemic has made the separation
between work and home difficult for
millions of canadians
and the trend of working from home could
be accelerating a hazard to our health
many canadians report they are working
longer hours
and as jamie morocco reports a new study
from the world health organization
found working longer hours is shortening
our lives
author rebecca eckler has been working
13-hour days launching her latest
project
and while it's paid off for her business
it could be costing her
her health at the end of the day my back
hurts
my eyes hurt every my brain hurts
and every day i wake up and i'm brain
fog
according to a new study from the world
health organization and international
labor organization
working more than 55 hours a week could
lead to premature death
stress in one's life both directly on
the body as well as
through its indirect impacts on some of
the health behaviors that people might
have
could contribute to the development of
many chronic diseases including the
study found a 35 percent
greater risk of stroke and 17 percent
greater risk of heart disease compared
to those who worked
35 to 40 hour weeks between 2000 and
2016
745 000 people died as a result of being
overworked
a number experts anticipate will be
accelerated by the pandemic
thanks to working from home and being
constantly connected
there is a sense of guilt there's a
sense of obligation maybe you should be
responding to the needs of your employer
hassan youssef president of the canadian
labor congress says it's time for the
government to step
in and protect canadians right to
disconnect it brings a very clear
message to workers
and to their employers that this is a
fundamental right they need to respect
but for those with their own business
like eckler the onus to take a break is
solely on their shoulders
i respect other people's time and
for them to have a work life balance but
if you're running your own little thing
then
you can't stop as a business person for
those looking for employers to make a
change yusuf says he has been in
consultation with the federal government
and hopes to see new legislation tabled
this summer
donna all right jamie morocco in toronto
tonight thanks
still ahead the u.s supreme court gets
set to revisit a landmark decision
about abortion
the u.s supreme court will hear a case
that challenges
roe versus wade the nearly 50-year-old
landmark decision in the u.s that
legalized abortion nationwide
it is the first time the new
conservative majority on the supreme
court will weigh in on abortion laws
the justices will take up mississippi's
bid to enforce a ban on most abortions
after 15 weeks of pregnancy
the ban had been blocked by lower courts
as unconstitutional under the supreme
court precedent
the 1973 roe versus wade ruling protects
a woman's right to abortion before the
venus can survive
outside the womb around 23 or 24 weeks
the court is expected to hear arguments
in the case next fall
a toast to reopening up next parts of
the uk allowed
back into pubs for a pint
a toronto man has joined a handful of
canadians to be inducted into the
basketball hall of fame
and it's not his skills on the court
that got him there he
is a super fan the first to ever be
inducted
nav bacha was honored in massachusetts
last night
today was a dream he tweeted in the
greatest building basketball has the
name
superfan nav bacha will be immortalized
his display includes a turban his
courtside seat and his original 1998
superfan raptors jersey bacha has
attended
every home game since the raptors became
an nba team
more than 25 years ago public health
restrictions eased today in
england wales and most of scotland and
you can imagine the reaction
at the stroke of midnight people were
free again to meet inside pubs for a
pint
glasses were raised and friends reunited
dining inside restaurants is also
allowed for the first time since
november
amazing absolutely amazing should we
have a chat
cheers attractions like the london eye
have reopened to visitors big and small
people lined up to get on board and they
also lined up to get away
a ban on foreign travel has been lifted
though it's replaced with new rules
passengers rushed to check in for the
first flights to portugal
one of 12 countries on the list of safe
destinations we've got
sun we've got the people the beaches the
bars
can't wait and this is the best part of
restrictions easing
hugs are allowed again between friends
and family who don't live together
and videos like this from the bbc say it
all
it's hoped the remaining restrictions
will be lifted june 21st
until then people have been urged to
cuddle cautiously
oh that's a good feeling and that is
global national for this monday i'm
donna friesen
tonight's year canada is this herd of
bison and elk island national park in
alberta
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you